I want to call you my Mac to something
in particular which is that we looked at
uniform distributions remember those
they're really simple everything in your
situation is the same probability right
and we've also looked at a bunch of that
are not uniform right some of them are
like increasing some of decreasing some
wiggle around all that kind of thing and
so we've just looked at all different
kinds of like all of these things
they're all just random other different
shapes right now what we've kind of not
been talking about is the fact that
there is one shape for our probability
distribution that is more important than
all the rest of the shapes it's like the
I don't know if they're any lot of rings
fancy right but it's like one
distribution to rule them all and it's
the one that's on a piece of paper I
snuck onto your desk just now it's what
we call the normal distribution okay now
you might you might sort of colloquially
any of you you you're welcome to write
this by the way you might look at this
shape and say I know what this is this
is called the bell curve right the bell
curve okay cause it looks like a bell
maybe that's not where your brain goes
okay but it turns out that this guy the
normal distribution it's like I said
it's kind of the most in the single most
important distribution that exists in
the world and there are lots of reasons
for that number one it happens all the
time
anytime you have something which is the
product of lots of independent factors
like how tall you are what temperature
is what scores you get on a test anytime
when there's lots of independent things
consuming something you get this shape
the normal distribution okay so because
it happens so frequently we're kind of
really interested in it so what I want
you to do with me is to note some of the
characteristics about this and then
we're going to sort of dig into what you
can do with it once you understand it so
the first thing is you can see that mu
there what does am you stand for again
that's the mean right the mean the first
thing that you notice is that this
distribution I hope you can see it's
kind of the same on both sides right
what word would we use to describe that
that started this it's symmetrical right
so the normal distribution is
symmetrical
about the mean about mute right now
speaking of mu mu is right there in the
center of the data quite literally right
so if you looked above mu and below mu
the area under the curve is the same
right so because this is a probability
density function if both of those halves
are the same then the area should equal
what each different side of it the left
on the right haha right yeah exactly
so we have a name for that value it's
not just the mean it's also the median
right it's that middle point and not
only are the mean and the median the
same but look the mean is also on the
highest point of the probability density
function which is to say it's also the
mode right so all three measures of
central tendency are the same on the
normal distribution okay now the other
thing you notice is that the the edges
of the bell if you like they get closer
and closer to the x-axis but they never
reach we have a name for that right we
call it asymptotic right
so a s Y MP Tod I see asymptotes well
actually some people spell it without
the P but anyway whatever okay say again
asymptotic so that's the adjective for
asymptotes okay now once you've got
these characteristics where you notice
this kind of shape right what we start
to realize is because you can start to
compare lots of different things instead
of saying oh your score is high because
this number or it's low because this
number we want to try and describe in
terms of common characteristics so
firstly we say and another color here we
describe how high or lowest score is
based on how far it is above or below
that middle value right which is both
the median or not both it's it's meeting
and it's the mood and it's also most
importantly for us it's the mean okay so
we might say you know yeah I I scored 50
that doesn't sound very good but I was
above the mean right so where the
average is really matters in terms of
whether something is high or low or go
to
right but then we want to go one step
further we say it is in terms of the
standard deviation because if you have
and I'm going to give you an example of
this in a second if you have a data set
oh by the way what is that symbol that
we use that Greek letter it's a sigma
right it's like a little Oh with a with
a little line there okay
the standard deviation tells us if
you've got a very very closely bunched
set of scores right so you got a low
standard deviation then to go above that
is a really big achievement whereas if
you've got a very spread out set of data
right and you're like oh I'm above
average you're like yeah but it's easy
to get above average by one or two marks
because lots of people are above by one
or two because everyone's spread out
okay so we have a name for this
particular thing when we tell you how
high although something is in terms of
the mean understand d--ation we call
this the z-score I'm putting it nice
involved because of how important is
okay okay no I know you might be exact
like 3d corners but Z is just the name
for and I'm gonna give you an equation
for the Zed's going to be heard the
phrase dead score before this is what it
means said equals it's a fraction so
what we do is we say firstly tell me how
far you are away from the mean this is
something we remember from expected
value from variance right so we might
say what's your score and then what you
do is you subtract the mean from that so
do you remember this from working out
variance okay it's like how far away are
you so that's X minus mu and then what
we do is we say we'll divide that now by
the standard I'm sorry divide that by
the standard deviation okay
the Sigma very good now like I said I'm
going to give an example of this so
maybe turn over your piece of paper
because we're going to come back to the
bottom of this in a second and why don't
you draw a table like this with me okay
so suppose you have a student maybe it's
you they've done two tests and they have
scores that seem very similar they score
75% on both tests and you go ahead and
you ask the teacher okay well I know 75
doesn't tell me very much tell me
the average was so they tell you the
mean on those tests was well by
coincidence you find out the mean for
both of them is sixty right now off of
this information here it looks like well
I guess I did about the same in both
tests but like I was mentioning before
the standard deviation for each test
changes this completely let me give you
an example let's suppose if for English
you then ask the teacher cuz you're like
I've done I've done random variables I
know to ask questions like this what is
the standard deviation for my English
test and they tell you it's ten okay
let's go ahead and work out what your
z-score is using that formula which
we've just written down okay the z-score
will be I'll write it just up above so
you can have it there X minus mu on
Sigma X your score
take away the mean so that's your score
there's the mean and then you divide by
your standard deviation okay so let's
just work out what it is for these
numbers okay you're gonna get seventy
five takeaway 60 that's X minus mu and I
divide by ten in this case because
that's just in deviation now seventy
five take away sixty that's 15 so 15
divided by ten would be one and a half
so we would say you got a z-score of 1.5
for your English and that's great that
means you're above average we already
knew that but this shows you how much
you're above average now suppose you
then go and ask the same question in
science and they tell you oh the
standard deviation for science was only
six now before we go ahead and calculate
the next thing think about what that
means standard deviation is a measure of
spread
how far is everyone sort of distributed
across the different marks okay so when
your standard deviation is only six
compared to ten what does that tell you
everyone's kind of bunched in more does
that make sense everyone is bunched in
more now look at what that means for
your z-score let's do the same
calculation it's still X minus mu on the
top but then you divide by six because
that's the standard deviation here now
if you go ahead and pop that into
calculator
it's 2.5 now just look at that for a
second right
we knew that your z-score for English
was good 1.5 but look at your z-score
for science it's way higher what this is
telling you is how many standard
deviations you are above or below if you
were below the average below the mean
now remember I said to you if you just
look at this over here you might be
tempted to think oh I scored 75 averages
60 so I did about the same in both of
them but for science because everyone is
so much more bunched together it's a
bigger deal that you were 15 marks above
average does that make sense you are two
and a half standard deviations above
average so that's like that's like wow
you're kind of a freak of nature to have
done that well on this test does that
make sense so do you see how when you
guys ask us like aw did I get about 50
percent or below fifty Cent that's
perfect isn't that doesn't matter as
much as what it is in terms of the
standard deviation that's why z-scores
are the things that truly are useful so
the Attar has more to do with that again
okay it's about percentiles which I
haven't really talked about you okay so
now let's have a look at and this will
give you a sense for what is wonder half
for two and a half mean what we're
comparing is z-scores what do they tell
you about where you sit in the
population okay so these graphs of the
normal distribution
you might notice on these bottom graphs
you've got numbers right 1 2 3 negative
1 negative 2 negative 3 and you can see
this is no longer an x axis you can see
it on your piece of paper I hope it came
out in the printout this is z axis now
right so what this tells you is if you
went and said oh that z-score of 1 and
1/2 that's around here between 1 & 2
right so there's your score that's where
you are in the population okay so the
z-scores tell you actually it's the
wrong color sorry they tell you where
you are relative to everyone else so if
you have a Zed score between negative 1
and 1 what that corresponds to is and
I've printed this out multiple times so
you can color it in what that
corresponds to is between these two
parts of the normal distribution from
negative 1 to 1
we'll get to the exact equation of this
line later on but once you have that it
turns out that you get about two thirds
68% of all scores sit between negative
one and one sit between one standard
deviation below and one standard
deviation above that's most of the
population okay now if you go one more
standard deviation out so if you go from
negative two to two you can see you're
now coloring in this larger section of
the population so when you have a look
at that area under the curve that's a
lot more than 68% right it turns out
it's about 95 okay so 95 percent of
population is within two standard
deviations of the mean
now if you go one more hour and you can
go further obviously but this is as far
as we tend to go if you go one more
standard deviation out so your z-scores
between negative three and three this
captures ninety-nine point seven percent
which sounds like a very funny number I
know but it comes from the actual
equation of the normal distribution so
that's between zero is negative three
and three so you can see for that score
of science you know I told you how to
z-score two and a half right so you're
somewhere around here so you're you know
you're better than 95% of that middle
population in fact it's better than more
than that but you're not better than
ninety-nine point seven okay so you can
see that's you have to be really really
far up above to get a score that high
now you might feel like that 68 95 99
point seven that seems very random that
sounds like really hot numbers to
remember which is why we don't make you
remember them they are on wait for it no
reference tree there it is so on the
statistical analysis section I want to
point out a few things to you okay for
starters right here up in the top look
at that Z equals what's that X take away
the mean divided by the standard
deviation right so there's that formula
right there
here is that bell curve
and they even tell you all of the
numbers they don't give you pretty
shading of course we can do that
ourselves but you've got 68% of scores
in the middle then 95% as you go further
out then ninety-nine point seven and
hopefully this stuff down here is also
ring a bell there's your expected value
and then what's underneath P of X what's
that that's variance right and the
different ways for working out variance
which we had a look at last lesson okay
so take a breath this idea of the normal
distribution is really really useful we
all of the stuff that we've been looking
at so if I want is quite theoretical
well these you're like ah some random
function which happens to be your
probabilities right that's gonna very
quickly give way to stuff that looks
like let me pull it out in your in your
in your Booker here you're gonna very
quickly see that we can now start
thinking about actual concrete
situations where you get given real
numbers and real quantities and you want
to say is that above average
is it very above average how can I tell
it's all in terms of your z-scores and
standard deviations okay